are you speaking to Nancy Pelosi our  teams are in communication our Chiefs  are but shouldn't it be a face-to-face I  want to know if you were the new member  not the speaker no but I was every right  to sit down with her in any moment  anytime with any of us she is Speaker of  the House she can ask for meeting to sit  down with us for clarification the fact  of the knowledge is and I've done racial  justice work in our country for a long  time acknowledge the fact that we are  women of color so when you do singles  out be aware of that and what you're  doing especially because some of us are  getting death threats because some of us  are being singled out in many ways  because of our backgrounds because of  our experiences and so forth but I think  the question interested in having a  conversation face-to-face absolutely  Speaker House Speaker Nancy Pelosi when  she sit down with her yeah no absolutely  and we've reached out to that